- You talk about,
everyone always
talks about failing
and you talk about being
scared of failing to who
and I love that.
'Cause that really gets
to the essence of it.
- Yeah, that's been--
- And hairdressers have
a lot of fear when
they're getting into the job.
- Got it. That was a big one.
I'm in a funny place where
I'm just not scared,
I'm just not worried about,
I have this weird,
I could care less what
anybody thinks and
I genuinely care what
everybody thinks.
You know, it's the kind of this
really Ying and Yang and so
I just realized that so many of
you are scared to fail because
your dad's gonna make
you feel bad about it.
I have empathy for that.
That sucks.
Or your husband is
going to say I told you so.
I'm very fascinated by negative
energy within our ecosystem that
is not cut out-able.
- Hmmm.
- You can get rid of your
acquaintance that's a dick face.
Right? But when your mom's the
dick face, you're in trouble.
- Yeah.
- And so I've been trying to
have this conversation of who
are you scared to fail in
front of and I gotta tell you in
one-on-ones or meet-ups
where the content has come from,
people are scared.
You look up to your older sister
who's straight lined and
her opinion matters to you.
But you're an artist and
you want to do this.
And if you fail, you don't
want to fail in front of her.
- Yeah.
- That's tough.
That's stopping a lot of us.
I don't have the answer to
what you have to do about it
other than I do believe that
communication solves all things.
But great, how do I push you to
have that real
talk with your mom?
Hard, so, yeah man.
- I love that.
- It's a real one.
- Yeah.
- But it's not so
easy to unwind.
(light music)